[Music]
if you had caught me straight out of
college in the halls of the Vermont
State House where I was a lobbyist in
training and asked me what I was going
to do with my life I would have told you
that I just passed the honey typing
culture the Chinese equivalency exam and
I was going to go study law in Beijing
and I was going to improve us-china
relations through top-down policy
changes in judicial system reforms I had
a plan and I never ever thought it would
have anything to do with the banjo
little did I know what a huge impact it
would have on me one night when I was at
a party and I heard a sound coming out
of a record player in the corner of a
room and it was it was Doc Watson
singing hymn playing Shady Grove she
loved Shady Grove my daughter loved
going back to her that sound was just so
beautiful the sound of Doc's voice and
the rippling groove of the banjo and
after being totally and completely
obsessed with the mammoth richness and
history of Chinese culture it was like
this total relief to hear something so
truly American and so truly awesome I
knew I had to take a banjo with me to
China so before going to law school in
China I bought a banjo I threw at my
little red truck and I I traveled down
through Appalachian and I I learned a
bunch of old American songs and I ended
up in Kentucky at the International
Bluegrass Music Association convention
and I was sitting in a hallway one night
and a couple girls came up to me and
they said hey do you want a jam and I
was like sure so I like picked up my
banjo and I nervously played like four
songs that I actually knew with them
and a record executive [ __ ] up to me
and invited me to Nashville Tennessee to
make a record it's been eight years and
I can tell you that I didn't go to China
to become a lawyer in fact I went to
Nashville and after a few months I was
writing songs and the first song I wrote
was in English and the second one was in
Chinese so fond of me like yeah you you
you outside your door the world is
waiting inside your heart a voice is
calling the four corners the world are
watching so travel daughter travel go
get it girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really been eight years since that
faded night in Kentucky
and I've played thousands of shows and
I've collaborated with so many
incredible inspirational musicians
around the world and I see the power of
music I see the power of music to
connect cultures I see it when I stand
on a stage at a bluegrass festival in
East Virginia and I look out at the sea
of lawn chairs and I bust out into a
song in Chinese young law and
everybody's eyes just pop right open
like it's gonna fall out their heads and
they're like what's that girl doing and
then they come up to me after the show
you're like they all have a story they
all come up to me and that you know my
aunt's sisters babysitter's dogs chicken
went to China and stopped at a girl and
I tell you what it's like everybody's
got a story it's just incredible and
then I go to China and I stand on the
stage at a university and I bust out
into a song in Chinese and everybody
sings along and they roar with delight
at this girl with the hair and the
instrument and she's singing their music
and I see even more importantly the
power of music to connect hearts like
the time I was in Sichuan Province and I
was singing for kids and relocation
schools in the earthquake disaster zone
and this little girl comes up to me long
dad Yi Chi Guinea Chinese hair will mama
she'll look at you big sister Wang
washburn wall same difference
big sister Wang can I sing you a song
that my mom sang for me before she was
swallowed in the earthquake and I sat
down and she sat on my lap she started
singing her song and the warmth of her
body and the tears rolling down her rosy
cheeks and I started to cry and the
light that shone off of her eyes was a
place I could have stayed forever and in
that moment we were in our American
selves we weren't our Chinese selves we
were just mortals sitting together in
that light that keeps us here I want to
dwell in that light with you and with
everyone and I know us-china relations
doesn't need another lawyer thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you